bom dia a good morning e gugu demônio
desejar já que gostei
aí tá eu já queria começar visando a
galera de brasília de 3 de junho tem
show aí o show tá [ __ ] 3 de junho no
ginásio nilson nelson às 18 horas
esperando você e toda sua família e seus
amigos chame todo mundo que vai ser
chutada topshop a foto dos meus três
show esse é o melhor e eu quero que você
confira então como seus ingressos
ingresso no site aqui um dia antes votar
em vitória no espírito santo na arena
vitória 21 horas está então quantos
ingressos também nesse final de semana
que vem agora é maceió alagoas nunca
tive eu casei em arapiraca alagoas um em
natal rio grande do norte lá no parque
lage no shopping vai ser top com seus
ingressos aqui tão junto é nós vamos
ouvir acabei de acordar e acordei muito
feliz porque eu e você acordou muito
feliz acordei muito feliz porque eu
dormi muito bem escuto vai crescer na
hora de dormir bem e quanto mais do
crédito vai perder qualidade de som da
criança criança tem um sono mais top que
existe no mundo criança dormir em
qualquer lugar porque ela gasta energia
o dia inteiro não tem nada pra fazer de
preocupação na torre corpo é como ela
não tem preocupação nenhuma com dez
gotas energia a dorbe em qualquer lugar
[Aplausos]
e em qualquer lugar
já virou criança dormir na mesa do
restaurante o nome qualquer lugar você
botar o dedo à panela ela do outro vai
crescendo a renda no buggy que tudo
consegue controlar mais a insônia você
simplesmente ficar acordado do nada
igual o parasita a com sono e não
consegue dormir eu tenho o rabo disso eu
tenho raiva de quem chama sony vai
crescendo para tudo me é a câmera cheia
de código é um travesseiro aqui do lado
não porque a minha lombar com crianças
nem sabe o que é a loba a assistir filme
de madrugada quando era criança e maria
melo é doida a maior dificuldade que
tinha eu botaria que eu falava hoje eu
não sou é macho pra não ficar acordado
até 11 horas da noite para assistir não
é tríplice que vai passar 11 meio da
noite eu não me chamo ibersol e não
ficar acordado até onze e meia da noite
wilker
r quem vai fazer o ipo a sala sentado no
sofá
hoje eu vou assistir silva botavam na
novela fala vou esperar juro por deus
nove horas da noite tá parecendo aqueles
caras da nasa que faz teste da força
gente fica assim a não fechar o empadão
do mês só assim eu fui só quis kaká não
queria só pisca pisca e quando abri meu
olho tá no globo rural fã
comigo é com a minha mãe que mamãe não é
quando o paciente tomar 30 e nesse ano
eu já tinha falhado e assistir filme
onze e meia da noite os 30 vez não foi o
primeiro ver não que eu tentei mas agora
quando tinha um sono top hoje eu tenho
que me preocupar para assistir todos os
filmes 'harry do mundo que o bota aqui
para assistir mas j bom num dos sítios
onu sinto eu boto e palmela carga de
papel ela cai de cartolina carga de
papel é um cara do que tiver qualquer
casa que tiver seja lá de que aquela foi
feito eu assisto a lusa chega e pergunta
do abdominal ele o que é a do vitória o
milan e que do youtube rapaz dominado
micronegócio fechou e deita tações coisa
ah não não quero não só nós que cita
como é que dorme acordar eu já conto eu
sei que eu tenho coisa pra fazer
responsabilidade eu fico com raiva de
acordo com raiva de domingo vou fazer
criança o sono pesado pesado que a
romaria como a criança não tem nada pra
fazer a corda vai ficar acordado em
outro mundo tudo é novo a vegetação que
cresce quando acordo e assim é a de mãe
perguntou pela mãe que é quem a pessoa
que bota comida na boca dela é isso que
ela faz gastar energia dorme acorda
alguém recarrega ela gasta energia dorme
acorda alguém que carrega quando você
cresce ninguém carrega mas então se você
não fizer você morre a criança vem de
outro tempo e espaço a gente acorda já
puto que já sabe o que tem que fazer a
igreja não queria ela acorda zé a ponta
até a corda falando as fala do sonho
quanto catar confundir não só não
concordou embora cola a escola foi ou
não é
quem eu tenho pegando o maico hora de
acordar aí faz call e raoni memórias
corte da grama foi 9 por enquanto vem
ao escovar bem
mhm jornal i embora sonho amar eu nem
conto meu sócio besteira eu só em coisas
nada a ver não tem pé nem cabeça nada
zero bairro chique demais as pessoas
encontrando o sonho gente ontem eu sou
eu acredito que eu sonhei que eu estava
de carro e eu fui até o supermercado
comprei um pouco de custos que eu fiz um
jantar para toda a família um prato
lindo inscritos aguardam do lado aquelas
coisas sensacionais jantamos todos em
comunhão a um acordo e meu sonho não tem
pé nem cabeça sei que estou conversando
com a pessoa que a luiza falou isso tudo
não libertar a que respondia na lg meu
pai fator bom eu até maquiné bem no
campo que campo bonito eu viro as costas
não é campo mas é a montanha é o pão da
montanha eu vou eu falo [ __ ] meu
irmão eu vou quando eu percebi que eu
vou eu não vou mais eu já caetetuba e no
concelho de novo do nada vem um dragão
gigante uso no meu ombro porque o dragão
gigante pequena gigante pontos com
efeito o dragão e será que solta fogo e
saiu da água pela minha mãe aparece a
minha mãe até a metade de baixo pra
baixo é por cavalo é um central com a
camisa do brasil que ela joga bola é
jogador de futebol centauro a mãe fala
mãe carol está muito diferente não falam
aqui é protagonizada no negócio michael
quem é não quer kaká arrancou na guarda
acordou da grã ao acordar a pessoa faça
o que eu digo nada que eu contei a
pessoa fala meu deus um golod de jesus
você chega um sonho dele para falar com
aquelas pessoas de significado do sonho
que significa meu som ela fala ia morrer
aí vai morrer certeza absoluta que já se
habitou no [ __ ] meu deus que a unia
jesus já sei que está tocando tipo no
rock in rio assim na na hora que comecei
a tocar num tava aí do nada virou hobby
mil que meu sonho e do nada eu tô pelado
e todo mundo andando a minha eu não sei
que o povo tá falando
é para dar o meu deus que me ajuda muito
a ver minha mãe falei muito o que eu tô
palavra falou não é que por causa do meu
lado me que carrega de novo é acordei
agora vou contar meu sonho pra você meu
sonho era acordar igual àquelas pessoas
de filme acorda suado sabe com a
mensagem que ela recebeu um sonho
a mulher do lado querido mensagem ele
estava indo atrás de mim eu acho chique
demais a contar desse jeito não acorda
senão o acordo com o espasmo espaço é a
coisa mais ridícula que pode fazer perde
o gol outra pessoa não tem nada mais
ridículo cair você se explica por cair
espaço não taquara domingo acontece isso
é ridículo ridículo de you eu tô com
esses problemas de dormir eu tenho raiva
que eu amo domingo eu acolho maior de é
dormir toda vez que eu vou dormir
alguém quer fazer suco e não é só aqui
não que todo dia faz subir de saque bota
no golpe o botafogo a equipe ou bebe no
dia que eu vou dormir aí eu quero suco
de frutas no liquidificador estão
pegando no são josé é a rapariga nessa
casa não é um cara querer dormir à porta
fazendo sucos é que a ae quais o sul
toma e nem me dá um pouco e me acordou e
daí enquanto dorme por cima do braço e
da cam dois estranhos a porno parece que
é um braço deve ser maior que eu tenho
tomic é o próximo do brasil e até agora
não se sabe quanto pesa na tua mão
parece estar pegando a mão de um cara
muito grande para termos do acordo que
eu peguei na minha mão parecia tanto a
mão de outra pessoa que eu falei boa
noite eu juro por deus então é isso se
você gostou do vídeo que gostei aqui
carnes ajuda de mais agentes ou seca de
brasília não esquece dia 3 de junho no
ginásio nilson nelson às 18 horas está
em ingressos na central de ingressos do
brasília shopping vitória no espírito
santo é dia 2 de junho local ea arena
vitória 21 horas com seus ingressos e 25
de maio 25 agora eu tô em maceió
ali pertinho de onde eu casei está no
ginásio do sesi às 20 horas a então
chama seus amigos dia 27 de maio em
natal no papai norteshopping tá com os
seus ingressos no site em vários outros
seu lado você vê tá então estamos junto
é nóis espero que tenha gostado e por
quê
mario